[Musik]
millionenschwere willen privat jets
luxusyachten russische oligarchen haben
ihren reichtum über ganz europa verteilt
die eu sanktionen sollen putins
unterstützer treffen wir wollen
herausfinden was es bisher passiert und
wie erfolgversprechend ist europas jagd
auf oligarchen vermögen
hier fallen einem sachen auf die füße
die man seit jahren einfach verschlafen
hat
die eine briefkastenfirma gehört der
anderen briefkastenfirma und so weiter
das gute ist ja dass man mit einer
immobilie nicht weg segeln kann keine
regierung der welt ist so schnell wie
alligatoren
rottach egern am tegernsee hier besitzt
putins lieblings oligarch alischer
usmanow eine villa mit bootshaus und
weitere immobilien gut geschützt von
bodyguards für viele millionen
luxussaniert muss man oft gehört mit
geschätzt 20 milliarden dollar vermögen
zu den reichsten russen steht auf der eu
sanktionsliste
dass er regelmäßig am tegernsee weilt
weiß jeder hier aber im grundbuch steht
sein name nicht wir fragen den
bürgermeister nach den
besitzverhältnissen
inwieweit ihm das gehört weiß ich nicht
ich komme nicht erinnern der bauantrag
ist damals von einer firma gekommen die
ist vielleicht wahrscheinlich ihm gehört
so würde ich das mal sagen und er heute
glaube ich mittlerweise noch drei
weitere anwesen erworben das heißt
gesteht auch gar nicht selber im
grundbuch oder wie das weiß ich nicht
das weiß ich wo es gemessen die dort mit
eingebunden war das wirkt damals der
bauantrag von einer firma gekommen ist
die agenten sitz in deutschland hat im
grundbuch steht die tegernsee limited
eine briefkastenfirma mit sitz auf der
isle of man der klassiker erklärt uns
konrad duffy experte für
finanzkriminalität
kein oligarch wird mit seinem eigenen
namen im grundbuch stehen dass da werden
also briefkastenfirmen aus anderen
ländern gebraucht die überschatten
finanzzentren oder steueroasen gehen und
so weiß man nicht wer der wirtschaftlich
berechtigte also der wahre eigentümer am
ende der eigentümer kette wirklich ist
und das muss jetzt eben langsam
herausgefunden werden das kostet eben
auch viel arbeit da wir in deutschland
zum beispiel beim thema immobilien über
100 grundbuchämter die sind nicht
digitalisiert die sind nicht digital
durchsuchbar während sich die deutschen
behörden noch sortieren hat ein
internationales recherche netzwerk von
journalisten mit der puzzle arbeit
begonnen trägt die besitztümer reiche
russen auf der sanktionsliste zusammen
im falle von usmanow privatflugzeuge
yachten immobilien in england spanien
italien kroatien
und das ist jetzt das tatsächliche
problem die vermögenswerte auch wenn
klar ist dass die oligarchen gehören
diese vermögenswerte verstecken sich
hinter einem labyrinth an
briefkastenfirmen und es ist schwer vor
gericht zu beweisen dass dieses vermögen
wirklich den oligarchen gehört und jetzt
wandern die werte schnell in andere
hände
das überhaupt bekannt ist welche
oligarch die tegernsee willen besitzt
ein glücksfall das zeigt uns auch dass
beispiel baden baden keine andere
deutsche stadt ist so eng mit russland
verwoben wie die kurstadt spezialisiert
auf russische luxus touristen verknüpft
durch gemeinsame geschichte beliebt als
rückzugsort reicher russen auf den
klingelschildern vieler willen lesen wie
romy nyse firmennamen gerüchte und
geschichten über russische
immobilienbesitzer gibt es viele fakten
keine
ob ihr jetzt oligarchen wohnen jetzt
kann ich nicht beurteilen es gibt ja
vermutungen dass wir eine oder andere
immobilie russischen staatsangehörigen
gehört der hintergrund war dass die sich
hier eine rückversicherung erkaufen
wollen wenn sie vielleicht man abbauen
müssen handlungsbedarf sieht die stadt
nicht
richten sie denn als
oberbürgermeister dem was man tun müsste
wenn ein solcher name auch von der
sanktionsliste in baden baden auf nein
das ist nicht die zuständigkeit einer
kommune in deutschland dass es
ausschließlich zuständigkeit des bundes
und des zolls und ich nehme mal an dass
von dort auch diese überprüfung
vorgenommen werden das läuft ja auch
wird das thema geldwäschegesetz was seit
vielen jahren ja auch den banken
auferlegt die entsprechenden
informationen weiterzugeben das entzieht
sich der sphäre einer stadt und insofern
habe ich da keine zuständigkeit
aus dem kanzleramt heißt es man habe
eine task force gegründet mit vertretern
aus über 14 verschiedenen behörden wir
fragen nach wie bei die task force ist
können sie dann gibt es dann in welcher
höhe
ist mir eine freundin boden bislang das
wird noch ein bisschen dauern bevor man
dort irgendwas berichten kann auch davor
man dort zahlen berichten kann da müssen
sie uns vielleicht noch ein zwei wochen
zeit geben aber ich denke dass wir so
wie ist etwas zu berichten die preorder
diese post das dann auch berichten
derweil bleibe deutschland das paradies
für geldwäsche erklären uns die experten
dieses deutsche bürokratie geflecht ist
extrem komplex und das führt dazu dass
es vielleicht das vorteilhafteste für
russische oligarchen ist um ihr vermögen
behalten zu können
es wird geschätzt dass jährlich 100
milliarden euro in deutschland gewaschen
werden und die antwort darauf war
einfach viel zu herzlos und lustlos
genau so merkt man auch dass zweifel die
taskforce jetzt 14 unterschiedliche
behörden koordinieren soll also die
kompetenzen sind einfach sehr verteilt
die behörden sind nicht so aufgestellt
wie sie zum beispiel in italien
aufgestellt sind
italien der hafen von triest anfang märz
die italienische finanzpolizei
beschlagnahmt öffentlichkeitswirksam die
luxusyacht des russischen milliardärs
andrej melnitschenko der 530 millionen
teure größte motorsegler der welt gehört
offiziell einem unternehmen auf den
bermudas
italien reagiert trotzdem
ich danke dem finanzminister der bank
italia und der italienischen
finanzpolizei für die hervorragende
arbeit die sie bisher geleistet haben
jetzt müssen wir alle schnell handeln
alle
handeln bevor es zu spät ist die devise
italiens denn gleich zu kriegsbeginn
beobachten hafenmitarbeiter das yachten
plötzlich auslaufen
einige dürften russischen
geschäftsleuten gehören eine die hier
lag gehört einem russen namens general
oft ist aber in see gestochen
sobald der ukraine krieg ausgebrochen
ist
bislang hat die finanzpolizei vermögen
im wert von 800 millionen euro
beschlagnahmt villen und yachten
darunter auch die lady m sie gehört dem
russischen tui großaktionär alexej
mordaschow der kurz vor verhängung der
eu-sanktionen seine tui anteile an eine
firma auf den jungferninseln verkauft
hat in italien beschlagnahmtes vermögen
bleibt erst mal für sechs monate
eingefroren
bereits seit 2007 ist es in italien sehr
viel leichter vermögen einzufrieren wenn
etwas verdächtiges
vorliegt und dafür gibt es eine zentrale
behörde die guardia di finanza die
60.000 mitarbeiter hat und jetzt eben
wirklich schlagkräftig vorgehen kann und
hier auf das entsprechende know how
zurückgreifen kann ist italien
profitieren jetzt von erfahrungen mit
der mafia in italien hat lange erfahrung
was es heißt sich mit komplexen
kriminellen organisationen
auseinanderzusetzen und genau das ist
russland eine kriminelle organisation
und deswegen ist italien besser gerüstet
während italien durchgreift versuchen
oligarchen roman abramowitsch offenbar
ihr vermögen vor den sanktionen in
sicherheit zu bringen
seine 162 meter yacht eclipse und eine
weitere superyacht liegen mittlerweile
in einem türkischen hafen der milliardär
wurde samt privatflugzeug in israel
gesichtet
ein bravo wird schon viele andere
oligarchen haben in den letzten jahren
immer ein freundliches gesicht gezeigt
sich als harmlose geschäftsleute
inszeniert als verlässliche typen so
versucht man darüber hinwegzutäuschen
dass sie natürlich auf putins befehl
hören
london einer der rückzugsorte russischer
oligarchen großbritanniens hauptstadt
trägt auch den spitznamen london grad
doch jetzt rühmt sich die regierung für
ihr hartes durchgreifen gegen russen auf
der sanktionsliste die briten haben
sieben mal mehr vermögenswerte
eingefroren als die eu die
außenministerin lobt sich selbst
wir sind in diesen tagen an vorderster
front mit sanktionen gegen den kreml und
für beschleunigen sanktionen gegen
russische oligarch vips doch ganz vorne
dabei waren list rus und andere
konservative politikerinnen als die frau
eines russischen politikers ihnen 160000
euro parteispende für ein abendessen bot
insgesamt zwei millionen pfund das
ergeben unsere recherchen sollen die
konservativen von russischen spendern
bekommen haben seit boris johnson
premier geworden ist auf betreiben
johnsons sitzt etwa auch evgeny lewe def
als lord lebe der von hampton und
sibirien im britischen oberhaus
die briten haben diese leute umworben
und rekrutiert viele der banken
kanzleien dienstleistungsunternehmen die
oligarchen helfen haben ihren hauptsitz
in großbritannien
russisches geld durchziehe london wie
ein unsichtbares netz erklärt uns anwalt
michael kufner und der muss es wissen
denn er berät viele reiche russen
regierung sie habe ihr die oligarchen
aktiv ermutigt mit ihren familien nach
london zu ziehen ihre kinder hier auf
die schule zu schicken englische
gerichte für rechtsstreitigkeiten oder
scheidungen zu nutzen eigentum in london
zu kaufen den britischer nationalität
anzunehmen all das ist über einen langen
zeitraum geschehen wenn sie nun eine
komplette kehrtwende in dieser sache
hinlegt muss die regierung sich also
zumindest ein wenig merkwürdig fühlen
so komplett ist die kehrtwende
allerdings nicht die usa und die eu
haben deutlich mehr oligarchen mit
sanktionen belegt als die briten erst
nach kurzem zögern hat großbritannien
das vermögen von abramowitsch
eingefroren das betrifft auch den
fußballclub des berühmtesten bewohner
london graz den fc chelsea
geschätzte 1,8 milliarden euro steckte
er in den club der nun zum verkauf steht
wegen der sanktionen darf der fc keine
spielertransfers mehrtätigen keine
tickets verkaufen und musste seine
fanshops schließen
also großbritannien das ein ganz
interessanter fall besseres transparenz
register als in deutschland zum beispiel
die behörden gehen proaktiver vorgehen
finanzkriminalität und auch geldwäsche
verhängen härte strafen aber ist hat
sehr lange gedauert bis wirklich auch
viele sanktionen verhängt wurden
das heißt es war ein bisschen der
eindruck dass der politische wille fehlt
denke wir können noch mehr von
großbritannien erwarten denn auch wir
wissen viel vermögen liegt in immobilien
in london zum beispiel vor allem im nord
londoner stadtteil highgate haben die
russen sich niedergelassen das beach
road house soll usmanow gehören das
anwesen wittenhorst wird einem
düngemittel magnaten zugeschrieben es
hat 25 schlafzimmer und einen
geschätzten wert von 360 millionen euro
nur der buckingham palace ist größer
die briten sind bisher die unterstützer
für russland gewesen sie haben die
oligarchen mit offenen armen empfangen
seit vielen vielen jahren
der andere europäische rückzugsort das
versteck für russische oligarchen gelder
der schweizer finanzplatz
genf putins jugendfreund milliardär und
ölhändler gennadi timtschenko lebt in
einer luxuriösen 18 millionen villa am
genfer see die über einen unterirdischen
tennisplatz verfügen soll dazu kommt
eine private flotte von flugzeugen sowie
eine reihe von hotels und villen mit
seiner frau fördert er über eine
stiftung sport und kultur in der schweiz
ja weil es die schweiz ist genau
deswegen ändert sich fast nie was in der
schweiz deswegen ist es echt erstaunlich
zu sehen dass sie diesmal das richtige
getan haben wenn auch zu zaghaft
[Musik]
lange hatte die regierung gezögert sich
den sanktionen der eu anzuschließen erst
nach heftiger kritik aus dem in und
ausland eingelenkt
warum haben wir so entschieden
andere demokratien sollen sich auf die
schweiz verlassen können
staaten die für völkerrecht einstehen
sollen sich auf die schweiz verlassen
können etwa 30% das auslandsvermögen
russischer bürger und firmen liegen in
der schweiz schätzungen gehen von rund
100 milliarden schweizer franken aus
die rolle des finanzplatzes ist enorm
man hat den eindruck dass alle
oligarchen der innerste kreis von putin
dann konten in der schweiz haben
da liegen wirklich hunderte milliarden
dollar auf schweizer bankkonten
russisches geld das extrem gut versteckt
ist und schweizer banken seien zwar hey
wir passen schon auf aber dann errichten
sie doch wieder neue systeme zum
beispiel trusts
gestrandet in basel mehrere
privatflugzeuge russischer besitzer
stehen hier auf dem rollfeld darunter
auch ein flugzeug das abramowitsch
gehören soll russische flugzeuge dürfen
nun nicht mehr starten doch die
beschlagnahmung von jets immobilien oder
yachten scheint nicht geplant in der
schweiz gibt man eben auch eher zaghaft
hier vor es gibt inzwischen auch eine
task force die die taskforce
vertraut darauf dass ihr sachen gemeldet
werden von anderen behörden und da merkt
man schon dass es eher ein
nicht so proaktiver ansatz generell
obwohl gerade in der schweiz es ein
geben müsste denn hier könnte also sehr
viel eingefroren werden was eventuell
auch alle gleichen wirklich weh tun
würde
es ist einfach ein beliebtes land für
wegen der anonymität und wegen dem
bankengeheimnis
und der handel mit russischen rohstoffen
geht weiter rund 80 prozent des
russischen rohstoffhandels werden über
die schweiz abgewickelt noch ist dieser
handel nicht von sanktionen betroffen
die schweiz verdient weiter kräftig mit
europas jagd auf olli gleichen vermögen
läuft in unterschiedlicher gangart und
wir fragen uns ob europa überhaupt über
genug gesetzliche munition verfügt um
putin oligarchen zu treffen
das problem ist dass wir der offshore
industrie erlaubt haben so stark zu
werden das wie russisches vermögen gar
nicht verfolgen können
wir müssen gesetze verabschieden die
verbieten dass briefkastenfirmen
irgendwas in europa besitzen wir müssen
wissen wessen geld sich in unserem
finanzsystem befindet
unser eindruck ist europa braucht
bessere gesetze gegen geldwäsche und
viel politischen willen um dem system
von putin und seinen olli gleichen etwas
entgegenzusetzen
[Musik]